finally one one final point which is
something a little more amorphous which
is when we talk about the future of
civilization and when we talk about
secularization and its impact on
religion and when we talk about Concepts
like truth one of the things we're
trying to find is is a the way we wish
to
live and when we think about how we want
to live I think it's important to
include within this whether you're
religious or secular I don't see how
anybody can really live without a
possibility of
transcendence now you could ask me what
I mean by Transcendence and we could be
here for a week uh but I don't see how
the meaningful life that we all aspire
to can be completely lacking in a
concept of transcendence and that's why
I think the real battle intellectually
philosophically the real challenge
before us right now really is about the
question of
materialism in the west we are living in
an intellectual and social environment
that seems to me to be unprecedentedly
materialistic and by materialistic I
don't just mean shopping though I also
mean shopping because consumerism is a
part of that indifference that I spoke
to I mean most people if you ask them if
they if God exists or not would prefer
to go
shopping and and that also has an impact
about how we live but I mean the idea
that all of human life and all of
natural life can be accounted for solely
in material terms now you can argue
about what the material causes are they
can be biological and genetic they can
be the kind of things that you
understand they are they are exactly and
they they could be economic if you're a
Marxist or you do a class analysis uh
you know Etc ET etc etc um but if you
believe that all of life human and
natural can be accounted for
materialistically and by all of human
life I mean also the Deep experiences of
human life the epiphanies the
experiences of courage and heroism and
passion and ecstasy and I mean the you
know the so-called Peak experiences
which come and go but they exist if you
believe that those experiences can be
accounted for in material terms you are
on one side of a line whatever you call
yourself and if you believe that
materialism cannot account for the
entirety of human and natural life in
the case of nature for example the
emergence of Consciousness which is now
you know the Catholic church has its
Mysteries science now has its mystery
which is how on Earth did Consciousness
emerge from matter right um but if you
believe that that m matter cannot
account for all of it you are on the
other side of the line and the company
there is very good Brian uh my friend n
wrote in 8080 in Morgan rout at the dawn
an age of barbarism is about to begin
and the science will serve
it do you agree with him I don't and you
know I think it's really worth exploring
in answering that question the issue
that Leon raised in such provocative
terms what side of the line are you on
you know are you on the side where it's
materialism or the language that we
often use physicalism that it's all
stuff or is there something Beyond stuff
and you're right we don't as scientists
fully know the answer to that question
but I strongly suspect it is all just
stuff governed by laws that can be
Quantified so I'm here to defend a
quantitative perspective and yet I don't
think at the end of what I say it will
come across that I
somehow am squashing or denigrating all
of the key qualities like the
Transcendent that you and I value so
firmly I mean if we put this in context
right 13.8 billion years ago the
universe at least the observable part
began in a rapid swelling of space that
was filled with energy that then
disintegrated into particles which under
the force of gravity collapsed into
stars and galaxies and planets and on
one particular Planet the detritus left
over from that process coalesced into
bags of particles that surge with the
currents of life and some of those surge
with the currents of intelligent life
and Consciousness we I strongly believe
are all just bags of particles governed
by physical law and so will we be able
to explain love and hate and jealousy
and Transcendence using this
architecture of mathematics maybe one
day I don't think there's anything
beyond the particles and the laws but
will that be the most useful explanation
no I don't think so if you want to
understand the Magnetic Moment of the
electron we should use quantum field
theory if you want to understand why you
have feelings for others in your
community or why certain historical
events take place I don't think we're
ever going to use the laws of physics to
explain the Crusades and yet I don't
think there was anything beyond the laws
of physics that was in operation and so
you need to have nested stories at the
fundamental level use physics and
particles and quantification in order to
Anchor your understanding or else you're
floating in a sea of ideas that you
don't know if they are right or they are
wrong the fact that we can calculate the
magnetic properties of an electron to 10
decimal places and then do experiments
and decimal by decimal show that they
are verified we can anchor our
understanding in the quantitative but I
would never use that language to talk
about things at the higher levels I
would use the language of ordinary human
discourse the words that we have
invented in order to capture these
wonderful qualities that we humans can
experience you just said and I repeat it
and because it's a famous line of you uh
we are all backs of particles ruled by
laws of nature uh um the human soul is
that one of those mystical things you
want to cut out say it one more time the
human soul is that one of those because
the human soul cannot be it's also back
of particles no look look let let's be
quite clear one of the things we're
talking about here is truth and that's
really where we began and Leon you
wonderfully noted that there is
something called truth and truth means
nothing if everyone has their own
personal truth I would say it's slightly
different even though I completely agree
with that I would say say there's
something called objective truth which
science attempts to reveal there's
something else called subjective truth
which are the truths that matter to me
as an individual and the things that
allow my life to have meaning and
purpose and if an individual finds that
the notion of soul is a subjective truth
that allows their life to have greater
richness and context and meaning and
purpose so be it as long is they
recognize that it is a subjective truth
that they don't try then to spread among
the objective truth that science is
really good at reveal you believe do you
believe that objective truth can be
sought outside the physical
sciences do do historians search for
objective Truth uh no this definition of
objective truth are the base facts of
physical reality and then what we do as
coherent collections of particles we try
to build narratives in order that
experience both personal and
society-wide makes sense and that's what
history
is